زلزال تركيا وسوريا ما زال العنوان الاول
في العالم وعنوان الوحيد اليوم ايضا
تفاعلكم اليوم يفند خرافات ماليه المنصات
من بعد الزلزال والعالم يسجل 245 زلزال في
48 ساعه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
حلقه جديده مشاهدينا نخصصها لاستعراض
مستجدات اخبار الزلزالين المدمرين اللي
ضربوه امس جنوب شرق تركيا وشمالي سوريا
واللي تم تقدير درجه قوه كل واحد منهم 7.8
و7.7 حسب مقياس ريختر وعلى عمق 17 كيلومتر
اعداد الضحايا والجرحى بتزيد وللان ما في
عدد ثابت وكل شيء يعني او كل شويه جلسه
تتغير واخر الاحصائيات انه تجاوز عدد
القتلى بكل من سوريا وتركيا 5000 قتيل اما
الجرحى فتعدوا في تركيا 23 الف جريح
و1500 في سوريا ومهم مشاهدينا اننا نشير
الى ان الاحصائيات في سوريا مو كثير دقيقه
لانه في مناطق للان ما قدروا يوصلوا لها
وينقذوا اللي موجودين فيها تحت الان
والسبب هو الامطار الغزيره والثلوج اللي
بتشهدها البلد وكمان نقص الامكانيات
والمعدات وفرق الانقاذ وطبعا الاحوال
الجويه الصعبه بتنطبق على تركيا كمان
وكانت منظمه الصحه العالميه حذرت من انه
رح يوصل عدد المتضررين اللي 23 مليون
متضرر وزير الداخليه التركي من يعني ثلث
ساعه كذا ووصف الزلزال باكبر كارثه
واجهتها تركيا في حياتها وقبلوا كان طلع
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان واعلن حاله
الطوارئ ثلاثه اشهر وانه عشره مناطق تضررت
من الزلزال وانها تعتبر يعني مناطق كوارث
اللي صار في تركيا وسوريا استنفر جهود
الدول العربيه والاجنبيه وصاروا في صراع
مع الوقت علشان ينقذوا الناس اللي تحت
الانقاض ويساعدوا المتضررين والمنكوبين
وبدات المساعده الانسانيه وفرق الانقاذ
توصل لكلا الدولتين من اغلب الدول
والمنظمات حول العالم وكانت اعلنت سوريا
عن تخصيص 50 مليار ليره سوريه يعني 20
مليون دولار لتمويل العمليات الاسعافيه
وتركيا اعلنت عن تخصيص خمسه مليار دولار
لعمليه الانقاذ
[موسيقى]
منصات التواصل مليانه دعوات للتبرع
والتطوع ودعوات للمتضررين وتزاول الصور
والمقاطع ولكن وللاسف ومثل اللي بصير مع
اي كارثه او حدث كبير كمان شايفين كثير
معلومات غريبه عجيبه متداوله على المنصات
نحن عارفين هذه حقيقه ولا خرافه ولا ايش
وانا ترى ما بتكلم عن تغريده الباحث
الهولندي اللي تكلمنا فيها امس واللي قيل
انه تنبا فيها بحدوث الزلزال لا احنا الان
بنتكلم عن اشياء اكبر من كذب كثير المنصات
مليانه معلومات وتحليلات الواحد مو فاهم
هذه حقائق مستنده للشيء علمي ولا خرافات
ولا تخبيص يعني يعني في منها صراحه من
غرابته واضح جدا انه تاليف لكن في اشياء
ثانيه فعليا الواحد مو عارف يصدقها او لا
يعني في ناس بتقول لك الزلزال له علاقه
بتوقف لب الارض عن الدوران واللي توصلنا
علماء من ايام وكنا حتى نناقشنا نحن في
حلقه سابقه من تفاعلكم وقال لك بس هذا هو
اكيد هو السبب والعالم خلاص بينتهي لانه
وقتها لو تتذكروا قالوا لب الارض توقف
وهيعكس دوران وفكل الشمس حتشرق من الغرب
والان زلزال فقال لك خلاص هذه علامات
الساعه والعالم بينتهي فينا ناس تانيه
قالت لك لا مو لب الارض بس السماء وقالت
لك الزلزال اكيد له علاقه بالمذنب الاخضر
اللي مر بالقرب مننا في الارض لاول مره من
خمسين سنه قبل خمسه ايام في ناس ثانيه عاد
قالت لك مو البشر اللي تنباوا بالزلزال بل
الحيوانات وتداولوا فيديو للطيور في تركيا
وقالوا شوفوا كيف حركه الطيور مو طبيعيه
اكيد كانوا حاسين وعارفين انه الزلزال جيد
ناس ثانيه قالت لا مو الطيور هذول اغنام
فاكرين الفيديو الاغنام العجيب اللي في
الصين والاردن من اسابيع واللي كده كانوا
بيلفوا فيه دوائر والناس قالت مو فاهمين
ايش هذا اليوم طلع الناس قالوا بس خلاص
فهمنا اكيد هدول الاغنام ما عاد حاسين
بالزلزال من قبل طيب كم تحليلات ومعلومات
بتخلي الواحد محتاج انه يسمع راي علمي
فينضم الينا دكتور محمد قاسم عضو مجلس
اداره المدرسه الرقميه انا محتاجه منك
دكتور محمد انك تكون هادئ وتتعامل مع هذه
الامور بهدوء والاشياء اللي حتسمعها بهدوء
طيب
خلينا نبتدي باول شيء قصه لب الارض
طبعا هذه لحد الحين انا ما شفت للعلماء اي
تجاوب على هذا الموضوع انه لبى الارض لها
علاقه او ما شابه فاعتقد في هذه ننتظر حتى
نشوف العلماء شو يقولون ولو
كان لب الارض هو الاشكال
لا سمعنا هذا الخبر من زمان اعتقد هاي
صفائح التكتونيه قاعد تتحرك وخلونا نشوف
بس احنا ننتظر لانه راي العلماء المختصين
في هذا الجانب هو الراي اللي ناخذ فيه
بالاخير طيب بسوي انه هو عاده تفسير انه
حدوث الزلازل بشكل عام دائما بيكون نفس
الشيء صح
نفس الشيء طبعا اكيد يعني دائما الصفائح
تتحرك وفي مناطق محدده تصير عندها هذه
الحركه الزلازل فهل لب الارض وتحركها او
تغيرها اللي قاعد يصير على مئات الالاف من
السنين او اكثر طبعا هل هذا له علاقه ما
شفت يعني لحد الحين خبر يتكلم عن هذا
الموضوع الى الان
خلينا ناخذ الموضوع اللي وراه لان هذا
اعتقد مو واضح وما ابي احط معلومه بتحلل
وبتربط الاشياء تعرف ببعض وخصوصا انه يعني
الزلازل صارت وقال لك خلاص انه يعني هذا
العالم راح ينتهي هذه نهايتنا يا دكتور
احنا المشكله الزلازل قاعد تصير في كل
مكان في حول العالم حتى في هناك خريطه
متكامله فيها تفاصيل كثيره
للزلازل على مر السنوات الطويله فهذا امر
يصير يعني قبل فتره في ايران في الولايات
المتحده في ما ادري في الدول هذه تصير
فيها دائما زلازل ساعات خفيفه وساعات
كبيره فهذا امر طبيعي يعني في ناس تعتقد
انه مثلا الله سبحانه وتعالى غاضب على
البشر فيعطيهم زلازل صديقنا جون مفتاح في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يدرس
الدكتوراه في علم الثقوب السوداء يقول
الزلازل تحصل في كل مكان حتى اعلى الكواكب
الاخرى حتى في الشمس يعني انا اعطيك مثال
انسايه اللي حاطينه على المريخ قاس
الزلازل قبل فتره يمكن ثلاث زلازل على سطح
المريخ يعني الله سبحانه وتعالى يعاقب منه
المواد العضويه الموجوده هناك مثلا فاعتقد
احنا احيانا نربط الامور بطريقه
[موسيقى]
الحيوانات عند احساس عالي باي تغير سيحدث
في الطبيعه او كارثه طبيعيه لاي مدى هذا
الكلام صحيح
هو سؤال وفي فيديوهات كثيره تبين هذا
الشيء قصصيا سرديا على مر التاريخ وهذا
مدون قبل حتى الميلاد بثلاث مئه سنه ان
هذه الاشياء تصير لكن علميا العلماء بحثوا
فيها ولم يبثوا في الموضوع ابدا الا انهم
يعتقدون ان الحيوانات فعليا لا تستطيع
اكتشاف الزلازل حتى لو تشوفون فيديو لا
يعني ان الفيديو دليل على اللي قاعد يصير
العلماء حتى على فكره راحوا الى مزارع
ووضعوا اجهزه على خراف وابقار يعني مجموعه
من الحيوانات في المزرعه ودرسوها لفتره
حتى يشوفون اذا فعلا هم يقدرون يكتشفون
الزلازل ولا لا ما وصلوا الى نتيجه يعني
نقدر نقول عنها انها قاطعه فهذا ايضا
نحتاج الى سنوات حتى نعرف وابحاث كثيره
يعني اكيد الخرفان هذه اللي بتدور مو هي
اللي تنبات يعني
[ضحك]
اقول لك ساره اعتقد في عندنا مشكله
يعني في بعض الابحاث العلميه شنو تقول
تقول ان الانسان لما يفقد السيطره على
الاشياء من حوله يبحث عن تفاسير تريحه
يعني واحده من التجارب اللي سوها على
الناس افقدوهم حاسس الكنترول على بعض
الاشياء والروهم صور فيها نقاط لما نقاط
عشوائيه ما فيها اي صوره ما فيها اي
معلومات قالوا لهم شو تشوفون في الصوره
فكانوا يركزون فيها اللي فقدوا الكنترول
على حياتهم او على تفكيرهم كانوا يشوفون
انماط وصور موجوده فيها بينما الناس اللي
ما فقدوا الكنترول ما كانوا يشوفون انماط
ويشوفونها عشوائيه تماما نحن دائما نبحث
عن الانماط المشكله وين تصير انه لما هذه
الانماط تكون خاطئه وما نبحث بشكل سليم
كثير من الناس يعني قاعدين يتكلمون بشكل
سخيف جدا ويعطون يعني وينهم وين كانوا قبل
الموضوع هذا كنتوا تقولوا لنا نبي يصير
زلزال اذا انتوا عارفين انه الخراف ولا
الابقار اللي تدور دائره هذه معناتها انه
راح يصير زلزال فاعتقد الموضوع مو
بهالسهوله هذه التحاليل اللي قاعد تصير
على الانترنت هذه
[موسيقى]
اعلم من جديد وسطنا العالم كله مو بس
العرب يعني مشغولين باخبار زلزال تركيا
وسوريا تفاجانا بخبر عن زلزال في بافل وفي
نيويورك اليوم زلزال بقوه 3.8 درجات على
مقياس
زلزال بتتعرض له الولايه من اربعين عام
زلزال نيويورك على زلزال جديد تسجل اليوم
في تركيا بقوه 5.7 على زلزالين امس
المدمرين طبعا رعبوا العالم خاصه مع اخبار
الهزات الارتداديه اللي سجلت لزلزال تركيا
وسوريا واللي تقدر بالمئات في تركيا بس في
310 ارتداديه تسجلوا من وقت الزلزال
الكبير وبعض الهزات وصلت ايران والعراق
والاردن ولبنان وحتى جرينلاند المركز
الاوروبي المتوسطي لرصد الزلازل قدر في
خريطه لايف كده بينشرها على موقعه انه
خلال 48 ساعه الماضيه في 245 زلزال ضربوا
العالم وهذول قوتهم اعلى من اربعه على
مقياس طبعا كل هذه الاخبار عامله حاله رعب
للناس هل الرقم هذا الطبيعي 245 زلزال في
العالم في 48 ساعه هل هذه الزلازل لها
علاقه ببعض طيب معهد رصد الزلازل الايطالي
قال انه سبب زلزال سوريا تحرك صفيحه
الاناضول خمسه امتار خلال عده ثواني هل
هذا كمان سبب باقي زلازل العالم خلينا
نرجع للدكتور محمد قاسم عشان يجاوبنا على
هذه الاسئله دكتور محمد هل هذا الرقم
معقول هذا العدد من الزلازل حول العالم في
48 ساعه
بصراحه ما اعرف الاجابه على هذا السؤال
اتذكر شفت مجموعه من الخرائط اللي تتحرك
على مدى السنوات وفيها زلازل كثيره لكن
مقارنه عدد بعدد ما عندي الاجابه على هذا
السؤال بالدقه طيب هل نقدر نربط هذه
الزلازل بشكل عام مع بعض يعني مثلا اللي
صار في سوريا وتركيا هل يمكن ربطه باللي
صار مثلا في امريكا او هكذا حتى مع بعد
المسافات هذه
ما ادري صراحه ما عندي الاجابه على هذا
السؤال ما اعتقد اني متخصص بما فيه
الكفايه حتى اجاوب هالسؤال بس هل تعتقد
حضرتك انه مثلا لما بتصير هذه الحوادث
يعني اكيد الناس حتربطها في بعض وحتفكر
فيها وحتتوتر من هذه الناحيه فايش الحل في
هذا الموضوع يعني خصوصا انه زي ما بتقول
مو معروف الاسباب كثير او ما في كثير
دراسات عن هذا الموضوع بس في حاله هلا
بصراحه حول العالم
لا صرع مساله الدراسات موجوده الدراسات
وربطها المتخصصين يعرفون الاجابات على هذا
السؤال انا ما اعرف الاجابات على هذا
السؤال لكن من ناحيه الناس وهذه المشكله
يعني الحين انا اجابتي هذه اللي اعطيتك
اياها هي الاجابه الصحيحه اللي المفروض
الناس يتقيدون فيها يعني ما يطلع واحد
بتحليل الخاص يعني انا الحين لو كنت ابي
اتشاطر كان ممكن اعطيك جواب من عندي جواب
ماله اي معنى نهائيا الناس هذا اللي قاعد
يسوونه الناس بدل
المتخصصين ويعرفون الاجابات منهم يروحون
من عندهم يالفون اجابات
وهذه الامن الاشياء اللي جالسين نحنا
بنشوفها اونلاين بالربط المواضيع هذه
والكلام هذا كله حضرتك من متابعتك لمواقع
التواصل ايش الاشياء اللي مثلا غير اللي
قلناها اللي فاتتك وحسيت انه الناس كيف
بتفكر
يعني احنا خصوصا في العالم الاسلامي احنا
عندنا هذه الاشكاليه الكبرى انه دائما
نلقي اللوم على الناس ونخلي الناس هم
السبب في ان الله سبحانه وتعالى غاضب
عليهم يا جماعه يعني في بعض الدول فقيره
وبعض الدول في حروب وبعض الدول عندها
مشاكل بما فيه الكفايه يعني ما تحتاج انه
احد يضربها زياده
فالمساله هذه طبيعيه والناس لو يفكرون
شويه بعقولهم لو يفكرون شويه بمنطق
ويروحون الى العلماء راح يكتشفون الاجابات
الصحيحه اللي مثل هذه الاسئله اما الاشياء
الثانيه اللي مثل الكائنات الحيه اللي
تدور او النمل اللي يدور حوالين نقطه
معينه هذه نهائيا مالها معنى اللي عنده
هذا النوع من الفكر عنده لخبطه تامه في
اكتشاف الروابط اللي مالها اي وجود في هذا
العالم فاعتقد احنا يمكن المشكله الاساسيه
اللي احنا نعاني منها هذا الاتهامات اللي
نوجهها للمساكين البشر اللي موجودين بدل
ان نطلب من الله سبحانه وتعالى العون لهم
وبدل من نساعدهم وتدزلهم يعني نتبرع لهم
طبعا انت اليوم غريت عن هذا الموضوع وكان
واضح غضبك الشديد من هذا الموضوع وبكل
الاحوال يعني هي الان مرحله فعلا الاساس
فيها هي محاوله انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه
محاوله انقاذ الناس من تحت الانقاض يعني
وحصر يعني انه او تخفيف يعني حجم الكارثه
اللي جالس بيصير حول العالم على العموم
نحن بنشكرك على هذه المداخله كان معنا
الدكتور محمد قاسم عضو مجلس اداره المدرسه
الرقميه شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
طيب غير الخسائر اللي لا تقدر بثمن من
ارواح المصابين في خسائر في المباني
والعمران مو طبيعيه وصور كثير متداوله اون
لاين مؤلمه لمواقع في تركيا والسوريه
ومنها قلاع ومواقع اثريه صمدت الاف السنين
وهزمها زلزال الامس
[موسيقى]
بس كل الاخبار والمقاطع والفيديوهات
المؤلمه لكلنا متابعينا من امس في بعض
المقاطع لعمليه انقاذ والخروج من تحت
الانقاذ بتعطي شويه امل وحبينا في تفاعلكم
ننهي حلقتنا اليوم بمجموعه من هذه اللقطات
ونكرر نفس نهايه حلقه امس الله يرحم
القتلى ويشفي المصابين ويخفف عن منهم تحت
الانقاض في امان الله
[موسيقى]
بابا بابا لا تخافي
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]